the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season eight video finally
HBO has released a very short teaser for
the final season of Game of Thrones I
know this is something we have all been
waiting for so now it might be time to
officially start getting hyped the
eighth and final season and Game of
Thrones is right around the corner which
means we should be getting a trailer
very soon when trying to guess when the
first trailer will be released is a bit
tricky but if you go back and look at
all the previous trailers from earlier
seasons you can see that almost all of
them were released after the new year so
if you have been wondering when the
official trailer will come out I would
say we should see the first one next
month
but that's just my opinion until then
let's talk about today's teaser
unfortunately the teaser they released
today is under 1 minute in length but I
think it did do a good job at
symbolizing what we can expect to see
happen in the final season it begins
with the mist rolling over Westeros this
is the arctic air that usually comes
when the night King is nearby what's
interesting is we actually see it freeze
the direwolf of House Stark if you have
been watching my channel for the past
year and a half
ever since season seven ended then you
would know that the night King is
planning to attack Winterfell not only
is this the most important target in the
north but it's also the home of the two
characters who have the closest
connection with the night king which is
brain stark and Jon Snow we have known
for quite some time that these two
characters were destined to face off
against the night King to me it only
makes sense that this would happen in
Winterfell which has been one of the
main locations since the very beginning
of the show there is no way the night
king invades Westeros without striking
that location most of you should already
know that I happen to believe the night
King and the television show is a stark
just like the night's king from the
books
this would mean Winterfell wasn't just
the home a brain stark and Jon Snow but
it was also once the home of the night
king now the big question still remains
does the night king completely destroy
Winterfell and keep moving south or will
the
start to be able to defeat him before he
freezes all of Westeros well if you want
to base it on this teaser it does look
like the night king will continue to
move south
the Starks may be left with no choice
but to abandon their ancestral castle
but as I have said time and time again
they will stop the night King the next
thing we see the mists freeze over is
the dragon we have already seen one
dragon get taken over by the night king
could we see another but this teaser
isn't just about ice it is promoting
Fire and Ice which we will see plenty of
in the final season after we see the
dragon freeze over we begin to see the
fire start to spread across the map the
fire actually engulfs the lion of House
Lannister this seems like it could be
symbolizing Daenerys defeating Cersei
Lannister which is something most of us
thought would happen eventually I do
want to say that I do love the visuals
in this teaser but I don't want to go
over analyzing this very short clip that
is something I will do once the first
official trailer gets released that's
when we will actually see images of
events happening throughout Westeros but
it's pretty clear that this teaser is
promoting one thing and that is Ice and
Fire
it's looking like Westeros will never be
the same after all the smoke has cleared
there will be dead bodies lettered
across the entire continent all the way
from the wall down to King's Landing the
battle against the night king should be
epic as well as the battle for King's
Landing one thing I know for sure is Ice
and Fire will clash next season and only
the strong will survive let me know what
you thought about this short teaser how
far south do you think the night king
will actually make it as I have said
before I don't think he makes it out of
the North alive but hey you just never
know anyways I have to cut the video
short because I do have to work tonight
but I will say this did get me very
excited for the final season now I am
really dying to see the first trailer I
can't wait to see some of the actual
footage from all of the epic battles to
come next season leave your thoughts and
questions down below and if you haven't
already make sure you subscribe because
as soon as that trailer drops I will be
releasing videos like a madman anyways I
want to thank everyone for watching both
of the videos I released today and I
also want to thank everyone for
supporting the channel on patreon I hope
you all have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
you
[Music]
[Music]